the U.S women's national team was this
close from getting eliminated from the
FIFA World Cup but the post saved them
by ending their game against Portugal in
a tie USA Alum Carly Lloyd really made
sure to not hold back on her thoughts
regarding the team's performance so far
she said she's seeing a very lackluster
uninspiring taking it for granted team
although these comments were pretty
harsh the team isn't performing even
close to how they're expected to they're
coming off of two back-to-back World
titles and the fact that they're not
winning multiple group stage games and
coming up as a runner-up in their group
for the second time ever I might add
it's very unfamiliar territory now
they're facing number three in the world
Sweden on Monday and they have been
historically very hard for the US team
to beat not only that but Rose Lavelle
is out for the next game because of a
yellow card that she picked up in the
second half of the Portugal game most
people think the yellow card is BS but
we're gonna have to see how the US does
without her